أنا شاب من برج الجوزاء عمري 26 عامًا من بار
[موسيقى]
شيفا اسمي يوسي شارفي وأنا صبي
53 أنا إيتاي سابيرسكي، 38 عامًا، من هاتف
الربيع نشعر أنني أشعر أنني قد تشرفت
مرتين بالفعل، مرة عندما لم يدافعوا عنا في بري
والمرة الثانية عندما لا نعود إلى المنزل
نتنياهو، من فضلك أوقف الحرب، أعدنا
في المنزل، نحن في ظروف صعبة هنا، لا يوجد طعام
المياه خطيرة هنا طوال الوقت، والصواريخ تسقط في مكان قريب
حيث أنا لا يوجد ماء
أنا آكل كل الوسائل، والجنود ينفدون هنا
إنهم يعاملوننا جيدًا، ويهتمون بنا كثيرًا
فمن الممكن وليس هناك الكثير من الوسائل
وضعنا مع استمرار الحرب يتغير
كوننا أصعب هو أكثر خطورة بالنسبة لنا في هذه الموجة
رأيت أنه يجب علينا أن نوقف الحرب الآن
في الهيكل
أطلقت عليه طائرة تابعة لقواتنا طائرة F16
شعرها ثلاثة صواريخ انفجر صاروخان وواحد
المبنى لم ينفجر، كنا بعض الجنود السحريين
وثلاثة كشافة، أنا شاب الجوزاء، إيتاي سابيرسكي
وجوزيف
بقيت بعد
أن الصاروخ أصاب المبنى الذي كنا نعيش فيه جميعًا
المهد، جنود السحر، نجح جنود حماس
لإنقاذ حياتي وشريكي ولكن من أجل آخر
ثم فشلنا في إنقاذ يوسي ولم ينج يوسي
عند هذه النقطة، بعد بضعة أيام وليلتين أ
نقلوني وأنا إلى مكان آخر وأثناء ذلك
لقد تضرر المقطع A الموجود معي
قواتنا فظيعة ولم أتمكن من النجاة، لقد أصبت
مع كدمات
في الرأس، الرأس كله في جروح، وبقية الجسم مصاب بي
توفي صابرسكي يوسف شرفي متأثراً بجراحه ووالد زوجته
أوقفوا هذا الجنون وأرجعونا إلى عائلاتنا
ما زال لنا حيا، ارجعونا إليه
لقد كانت ميريك في المنزل، يا أختنا، أوقفي هذا الجنون
وهذا سوف يعيدنا إلى عائلاتنا طالما
نحن على قيد الحياة، أعدنا إلى المنزل، أعدنا
أعدنا إلى المنزل أعدنا إلى المنزل أعدنا إلى المنزل
نحن
البيت